this is the fifth time Germany has had a
place on the UN Security Council another
two years in the diplomatic hot seat
means taking sides on some tough issues
as foreign minister Heiko Maas
recognized when Germany was elected last
summer if I want to live up to this
responsibility we don't want to shy away
from difficult decisions we want to
stand up and be counted
father Buckhannon diplomats at the
foreign ministry in Berlin have
ambitious plans they want the UN to
react sooner when conflicts develop such
as those in Syria or Ukraine and they
want to use their seat in New York to
prevent missiles being stationed in
Germany in the event that the United
States pulls out of the INF missile
treaty positions like these could
require tough talk and readiness to
follow it up with action Mateus Assad's
father being a member of the Security
Council means you don't always have time
to hold a meeting in Berlin or think
things over you have to be clear in
advance how you want to position
yourself then you have to vote will have
to say which side were on the Kenan
perhaps the trickiest part of Germany's
UN mission could be the European
dimension with Belgium and Poland
currently also on the Security Council
alongside permanent members France and
Britain the EU is well represented
Germany wants Europe to speak with one
voice ultimately to hold a joint seat
but that aim will inevitably face
resistance from countries that worry
about losing influence and in the era of
Donald Trump multilateral institutions
like the UN have themselves been called
into question Germany will try to use
its seat at the table to restore trust
we have to defend order with our friends
and partners but we also have to deal
with those who don't see things as
Germany does DDoS this cancels the envy
doctrine plenty of battles for Germany
to face over the coming two years